okay so it's been a few weeks since
we've checked in with the lost souls
over on reddit's relationships forum so
i thought we'd do that today
many of the questions uh we'll deal with
today have a similar theme
okay so we'll begin here i have been
friends with this girl for a long time
she's my only best friend and i'm
only hers too we were very close and
went through much together but
we never really considered being
romantically together or talked about it
we were always clear about this we're
not interested in each other
romantically hence nothing ever happened
between us
she had relationships while we were
friends and so did
i by the way that was all one sentence
what i just read there um
there were always troubles because how
close we are but they seem minor since
we're young
early 20s and their relationships
weren't serious about a year ago she
started going out with an older guy and
shortly got engaged and married recently
i met the guy many times and he's a nice
dude i acutely
don't mind at all probably means
actually don't mind at all i guess
i acutely don't mind now you're being
acute
my my lack of care is acute i don't know
maybe that makes sense i'm not sure if
he's going for that or not
saying he isn't okay with our
relationship is an understatement they
had many fights because
uh she met and sat to talk we worked
together or because
she still had something i gave her etc
he never talked to me
about it but she told me that many times
so i told her that i'm okay
with whatever boundaries they want to
put and i would respect it
but she just isn't accepting that she
feels that she's giving up her life for
him and that marriage doesn't mean
living in a prison just to make the
partner happy her words
yesterday she wanted to meet i thought
the three of us would meet
but i found out on the spot that he's
traveling for work and only the two of
us
we spent a good three hours talking and
catching up i really don't know what to
do in the beginning i thought she is the
one
who will need to put boundaries and i
will only follow
but she isn't doing anything and this is
putting her in a lot of trouble with her
husband
i feel i'm doing something wrong and i
don't know what to do
well use some periods would that's one
thing you could do and really help me
out
should i put the boundaries should i
refuse to meet up should i not talk to
her as much
that would hurt both of us i'm sure but
i'm willing to do it for the sake of all
of us
what should i do okay now i read the
replies to this question and most of
them as expected were
awful okay everyone seemed to be taking
the side of this woman
and uh saying that the husband is
controlling and abusive and all this
kind of stuff that's
like that's why you should go to reddit
for advice because that's what you're
going to get
nothing could be further from the truth
the opposite is the case here right
um the woman is 100 the bad guy here
100 without a doubt she complains that
she's that she has to give up her life
for her husband well yes
darling that's what you do when you get
married you got married didn't you
if you weren't interested in doing that
why did you get married
that's what marriage means it means
you're giving up your old life and
you're starting a new one the phrase you
know you often hear the phrase when
people get married
they're starting a new life together
well yeah it's that's that's
literally true you're starting a new
life together that doesn't mean you have
to give up everything
you have to give up everything that you
ever enjoy you don't have to change your
personality entirely or anything like
that but it does mean
that your life is going to fundamentally
uh
change and your priorities are going to
fundamentally change
and now you're going to have this other
person in your life who you have to put
before
everyone else okay they have to be your
priority one of the changes that people
often have to make when they get married
is their friendships very common thing
there are certain friends you won't see
as much in fact all of your friends you
won't see as much
um certain things that you used to do
with your friends that you you won't be
able to do anymore
uh you probably aren't going to be
hanging out at a bar until 2 a.m
every saturday uh if you're a married
man or a married woman
and yes if your best friend pre-marriage
is a member of the opposite sex then
that's going to need to change
that's going to be a big change but it's
going to have to you cannot have your
number one confidant and companion
outside of marriage be a member of the
opposite sex you're asking for trouble
you're setting yourself up for failure
you're setting your spouse up for
heartbreak
no good can come of it like nothing good
can come it's just a matter of how bad
is it going to be
those are the that's the only thing
there and this is perfectly illustrated
by this woman who's putting her
friendship with the other guy
above her relationship with her husband
so even if this friendship has never
been sexual that should tell you
something right there
that she is emotionally attached to it
so much that she would put it above her
relationship with her husband
and she's confiding in this other guy
complaining
about her husband to this other guy i
would argue that's already a form of
emotional cheating
when you're confiding in a member of the
opposite sex about your spouse
and complaining about them you're
already in the realm
of an emotional affair if not a physical
one
what all this means is that you need to
break up with your friend
affliction that's what that's that's for
for her own
good for the good of her family for your
good that's what he's had
okay um next question my girlfriend of
two years went to a party this weekend
and when she came home she told me that
a guy had kissed her and she pulled away
immediately
telling him she had a boyfriend this
morning she told me that the kissing was
mutual and they got in bed together
after more kissing he pulled her pants
down and that's what she supposedly
called it off
is this cheating
is this cheating what no tough question
uh it would be hard to uh to get that
trust back with her the really hard part
is i live with her we both just renewed
our one year lease
in the same apartment where both broke
college kids and would have no way of
making other housing arrangements
she's been hysterical all morning
begging me to stay with her i love her
but how will i trust her again
what do i do what would you guys do
um okay you're asking if that's cheating
yes that's like the dictionary
definition of cheating
look up cheating in the dictionary and
there's gonna be a picture of your girl
with this other guy so actually don't
look it up that's gonna be upsetting to
look at
um but you get my point how will you
trust her again well you won't
you can't you never will you could try
you could lie to yourself tell yourself
that you trust her but really you don't
um you can have a lot of long emotional
conversations where you supposedly are
working through your issues and
she comes up with all these elaborate
explanations about why she behaved the
way she did
and you know it all comes down to it's
not really her fault and
she'll tell you about her history and
she'll come up with all this kind of
stuff and you could do all that you
could drag this on for another two years
if you want
until you break up anyway either because
she cheats again which you probably will
or
because you could never get over the
first offense and you certainly can't
see yourself moving to the next stage
like marriage when she did this
so you can do that or you could just
break up now those are your choices
i think we know which is the best one
bafflation um finally
another question says i've decided that
it's for the best that i leave my
boyfriend of two years i rent my own
place
he does not work and i've supported us
the entire time
he also doesn't clean up after himself
until very recently
i plan on renting a nearby apartment or
townhouse and i constantly visualize my
perfect little place
just the way i like it without anyone
telling me what i can or can't do
he moved my bed in the corner of the
room and forced me to sleep on the side
facing the wall
having to crawl over him to get out
never
letting that happen again with anybody
my problem is
i've never ended a relationship before
i've been wanting to break up over a
month and i don't know how to execute it
at all i hope you don't know how to
execute the breakup not not your
boyfriend
i hope you mean do i sit him down and
tell him
i want to break up or do i send him a
text message when i'm not at home
why can't i just do this why is it so
hard for me to just take the leap
it's so hard but my lease is ending soon
so i need to grow some lady balls and
figure it out
[Music]
please leave any helpful advice thank
you and have a great day
i'm really glad i read the line that
said lady balls do girls not have boughs
girls do not have balls no um well my
feelings on breaking up via text are
known i'm you know i'm in favor of it
but in this case since you live together
that is gonna make it more
awkward like you'll send the text
and then you're gonna come home and he's
in the kitchen
and then what are you gonna do you're
gonna say so um
did you get my text earlier about ending
this
he just left or what if he doesn't get
your text
and and then because like he doesn't
have reception and then you're both at
home
sitting on the couch and it finally
comes through and so you're sitting next
to him on the couch
while he reads this long emotional text
from you about how you want to break up
you got it that's not good you got to
think about those things so in this case
face-to-face conversation make it simple
make it short don't say anything don't
say anything that begins with the phrase
i want okay you're not saying i want to
break up
you're not thinking about it you you're
just you're saying that you
are okay we are breaking up don't give a
lot of reasons
because he can always try to fix it
right if you give reasons
so if you say that he's messy or
whatever or he moved your bed to the
side of the room he can always say well
we'll move the bed back if that's what
this is about
it's fine we'll move the bed back all
you need to say is i'm breaking up with
you this relationship is not working for
me
i don't want to be with you um we aren't
a good fit and we'll never be a good fit
and that's it
bye felicia right you want to keep it
broad but definitive
that's the key make sure he knows that
the situation is hopeless
like one out of a million and that he
has no choice
but to plunge into loneliness and
despair he cannot escape it it's coming
for him
he's got to just dive in and accept it
the good thing is it won't last forever
he'll get pilgrim over and so will you
and everyone will be fine
so you're telling me there's a chance
now one other thing here
i wanted to read these last two together
for a reason
because in both cases the couples live
with each other
right and this has made the breakup a
million times more complicated
and it also gives them both incentives
even though they're both in
relationships that they know need to end
it gives them an incentive to keep it
going to keep the doomed relationship
going
just because it's a lot easier
logistically and you don't have to deal
with all the awkwardness and everything
and uh of moving out and doing all that
this is why i say
one of the reasons i say and i've always
said that moving in together before
marriage is a big mistake i know that
people don't want to hear it a lot of
people watching this right now
probably are living with her you might
be watching this
with like your girlfriend who you live
with and so it makes it awkward but
i understand that but it is a mistake it
just is
because you're taking on one of the
major commitments of marriage
that is sharing a home that's a big
commitment
that's a big deal to share a home with
somebody
but you're doing it without the actual
underlying commitment
of marriage so you don't have that
that stability of that underlying
commitment so the best
comparison it's like i don't know it's
like going
scuba diving with all the equipment but
the oxygen tank
you're only guaranteeing that you're
going to find that you're in too deep
pretty soon and you're unprepared
don't do that to yourself don't play
house with your girlfriend or your
boyfriend
stay separate enjoy your independence
and your own bed and you could put the
bed wherever you want and sleep anywhere
you want on the bed
enjoy that part of of of that um
and then uh and then when you're ready
to get married then you're ready to
give all that up so keep the cart behind
the horse is what i'm saying
and that's a positive note or about
as positive as i will ever get to end on
so thanks for watching